[Music]
thank you
look at this NASCAR win this is so
ridiculous man
what is he what did he do so he needed
points for the championship You Know
Places one through ten
oh here we go here we go oh dude
so he needs two points
so it's the last lap
I can't believe what I just saw like so
I don't understand he did he purposely
do that yes okay so let me explain
because they don't do a good job of
explaining it
they need like some gen Z person to be
like if you think NASCAR's stupid wait
till I show you this this is Jerry
almendinger
now what it was was that he needed he
needed two points
uh to I think win the championship
that's what I believe but basically he's
down on points and he just needs a
certain amount of points to get the
championship
so they're on the last lap
and he's he's stuck in tow like all the
cars are like one after another so the
slipstream is like pretty nailed down
and if you get outside of that you're
gonna lose time because it's like I
guess it's like a short track the oval
track he goes [ __ ] it
and he just floors it and does the video
game thing oh okay yeah and just wall
rides the [ __ ] to the finish line
so you just did he get the two points
yeah he did he jumped like four places
holy [ __ ] like now run it back now run
it back and you see how many cars he
jumps ahead of it's insane
so he needs two points
and he goes [ __ ] it
he hops all those cars bro God
look how fast that is oh
my God is he the first person to do this
I think maybe so why don't people do
this if it works so well like because of
the money it's like I mean the car is
shot okay yeah you know like you could
only you know but now that that's
probably gonna they're probably gonna
have to make a rule like hey hey okay no
video game [ __ ] no video game moves
[ __ ] this is NASCAR here's the
thing I don't know how many cars could
survive that type of also yeah aren't
you like it's not like a serious risk
yeah it's like insane yeah look at dude
look at that run that back holy [ __ ] you
cannot sit here and be like
pretend that you would have the nutsack
to do this
oh my God
that's like Formula One speed right
easily 160 miles an hour
my God
you know NASCAR started because of
prohibition
hold on one second oh
cool let me get shoe time actually we
should go into the bone oh we weren't
done with Jerry almendinger
oh let's let's get into this for a
second is that his name no but that's
like a driver's last name Alma Dinger I
was telling you NASCAR commentary is the
best yeah
oh man we ain't never seen are we gonna
run him wide oh look out I'm a digger
coming right back he's going back he's
shoving it right in the back of Dixon oh
man he sent him oh good lord
now I'll tell you that's real race car
driving right there
Real Racing are you gonna get your
elbows wet shut me off at turn one I'm a
digger comes back and says here Dixon
take this down here and turn 12. yeah
that down there it turned 12. that's a
tricky one because if you get the rear
left of that the the car gonna step out
and just it's gonna yep just like that
spin on you man we gotta get we got to
get the realism back in these video
games okay look at this [ __ ] this is a
video game
NASCAR video game if you try it
[Music]
oh it [ __ ] you what it just like makes
you crash yeah it spins out probably
because kids just
we'll we'll do that [ __ ]
unapologetically and win the thing is
that probably happens in real life too
he probably just got lucky
yeah no for sure like there was this
there was a serious chance that his car
just could have like erupted in flames
right I think I assume the gas tank is
on the left side let's take a look at
what he did I have never seen anything
like that that's so sick dude
he also like isn't that kind of a risk
to other drivers too
definitely oh this is someone doing it
in a video game
is that a video game yeah the it's like
a picture in picture yeah Elena just
sent me some relationship humor and God
damn it is it funny what is it
you get the full caption here so Elena
talks pretty softly or at least with me
man can iMessage ever not be a piece of
[ __ ] does anybody else's girlfriend get
mad whenever you ask her to repeat
herself even though she's the one
talking like we're in a public library
so we'll start over one more time does
anybody
[Laughter]
I get that too
with Elena
I I try to tell her I say the way you
speak to me is softer than other people
with other people friends enunciating
volume
professionalism with me
I'm just feeling like I just
what what yeah and I kind of feel like
we talk too loud because there's that
too where I'm always like we're in like
an Uber or something like that and I'll
just be way too loud yeah she's like can
you yeah always always yeah
I'm like he doesn't care yeah there's
also that part when you date someone for
a long time where they kind of expect
you to know things about them
so they feel compelled to like not
necessarily give complete thoughts so
that you just combine those two and what
yeah yeah huh
you ever like say something
under your breath that you're just like
saying to yourself
[Music]
and then she'll be like what and you'll
be like never mind yep it's like
literally it was just me talking it's
not important at all no was it like what
was it no it was it no tell me no it's
gonna be more effort for me to try and
for both of us to try and understand
what the [ __ ] I just did okay you have
to trust me no it's fine saying this
does not matter at all it's fine I
promise it doesn't matter okay
I just this makes me sad because I think
like
like this is like this is what couples
do we're not communicating like you're
just not telling me like what you're
thinking and like now now I'm just
thinking about it now I'm just in the
dark so it's fine yeah
okay I was thinking like
I need looser underwear because when I
walk now my dick and balls it just kind
of moves around in a weird way
oh she's like oh I wish I never asked
see I told you
so let me have my thoughts
it's kind of like it's kind of like
those memes where it's like what she
thinks you're thinking about and what
you're 100 it's just you're just like
always it's both I've nothing going on
yeah there's not no thoughts ever yeah
if I mumble it's just because it's like
a a noise that just came out from you
know I love I I
really am thankful for the women that
get on Tick Tock that like seek to
educate their peers they go ladies when
your man is quiet sitting there
and you're wondering what's he thinking
nothing
nothing
she's like I know I know you don't
believe it I know you don't believe it
but men are capable of thinking of
nothing
are you can you do that yes yeah yeah
I I'm always thinking but about stupid
[ __ ] yeah you know yeah I'm thinking
about not about things that matter at
all yeah I'm thinking about my garage
yes
yeah and what construction you're gonna
do to it
well I'll get the [ __ ] no no dude
it's even dumber
well I saw the Ryobi Cirque saw is about
140 but the Milwaukee certain saw is
only about 180 and I feel like even with
the cost difference I might as well just
future proof it what do you what's going
on in there
oh nothing
it's nothing
yeah that's exactly what it is really
about dumb [ __ ] yeah so you know what I
started doing though well I started
vocalizing those dumb things and then
now I've got Alina to go in the other
way sometime until she doesn't okay I
don't huh
no no let's talk about the garage door
no let's talk at length
and how I want to roll up garage door
because I've been thinking about this
all day yeah I've been thinking all day
about how I could get a lift in there
that's what I've been thinking about
yeah dude so you want to put a lift in
your garage for your car
um no no so I'm gonna I'm gonna prep the
garage to do that in case I decide later
okay
nice
well no because the concrete in my
garage that's really funny it's
compromised
so you're thinking about thinking about
something later yes
well you're thinking about prepping for
when you think about doing something
later well I'm I'm going to redo the
concrete okay so I have a more even
surface yeah and the concrete's just
[ __ ] because my house is older right
um
and then once I have the even surface
well first I'm gonna you know I'm gonna
clear out the cross brace in the garage
right of course yeah and then and then
we'll do the concrete talk about
something else yeah no and then
I'm actually I'm actually getting a a
third row of of track lights installed
right now oh nice yeah
and so you know
um the concrete will withstand the
pressure of the lift if I change my mind
I see so I can install it later and the
lift is for your car
yeah so you can get under there and
start doing some maintenance I could
Tinker around yeah tanker you know yeah
maybe undo a nut there
secure something over here I'll be doing
all kinds of nuts oh yeah because mine
stopped working so I gotta start I gotta
play some other nuts
are they all bags you know Twisted every
every last bit of that nut in there it
don't work no more
your own ball and chain let me tell you
the first thing to go to your nuts
that's what goes
first thing in the marriage nuts they
just go out the window